mais d'abord donc le quoi qu'il en coûte
de retour cécile 6 ou quelques jours des
législatives le gouvernement accélère le
calendrier des annonces il veut rassurer
les français sur le pouvoir d'achat et
notamment sur la promesse de chez
qu'alimentaire si son avenir est
aujourd'hui incertain il compte tout de
même mettre en place une et d'inflation
pour les ménages modestes
cette indemnité arrivera et je crois que
c'est le plus important à la rentrée
comme l'a dit la première ministre
elisabeth bornes directement sur le
compte en banque des français elle la
puise à permettre aux français qui ont
des difficultés
de pouvoir continuer à acheter à faire
leurs courses comme il le faisait avant
outre nouveauté les retraites seront
revalorisées de 4% dès le mois d'août 18
millions de français sont concernés
enfin ceux qui travaillent ne paieront
pas plus d'impôts si leur salaire
augmente à cause de l'inflation nous
allons indexé le barème de l'impôt sur
le revenu sur l'inflation pour éviter
justement ses effets comme vous dites
très bien de seuil où des gens qui ne
paieraient pas l'impôt sur le revenu
avant à cause de l'inflation des
augmentations bascule basculerait dans
l'impôt sur le revenu ou basculerait
dans une tranche supplémentaire et man
ça vient nous indexons c'est exactement
nous augmentons les seuils du montant de
l'inflation le gouvernement veut aussi
aller vite sur la crise des urgences
président bourguignon la ministre de la
santé n'a pas attendu les conclusions de
la mission flash pour dévoiler cet après
midi des premières mesures elle a
notamment promis avant l'été l'ouverture
de postes aux élèves infirmières en
l'obtention de leur diplôme et des
heures supplémentaires payées double
pour les soignants
ce train de mesures évidemment mais
aussi une projection vers les sla type 2
dimanche le premier tour c'est dans
quatre jours on en débat tout de suite
avec claire chartier bonsoir bienvenue
vous êtes journaliste essayiste thierry
pech bonsoir et bienvenue directeur
général de terra nova j'accueille
allemand bruno cautrès politologue
chercheur au cnrs et au cevipof bonsoir
bruno et matthieu croissandeau
éditorialiste politique que bonsoir man
histoire claire j'ai commencé avec vous
ces mesures annoncées par elisabeth
borne est ce que c'est de l'opportunisme
politique on est quand même à quatre
jours du premier tour bon évidemment on
peut le penser il ya d'un point de vue
politique stricte il y a deux objectifs
c'est d'abord de ne pas laisser le champ
libre à la nuque puisque le pouvoir
d'achat c'est quand même le grand
flambeau à jean luc mélenchon il a
annoncé des mesures assez massue et qui
était assez spectaculaire dans le débat
le smic à 1500 euros le blocage des prix
donc évidemment il faut quand même
répondre sachant que le pouvoir d'achat
en fait c'est un sujet qui n'est pas
associée dans l'opinion spécifiquement à
un parti il est assez partagée dans la
compétition électorale
malgré la campagne parce que je pensais
à marine le pen
oui pendant tout entier donc il ya quand
même un coup à jouer pour
le gouvernement et puis évidemment on le
sait aussi les électeurs en fait vote en
fonction des priorités du moment et ils
votent en faveur des candidats qui leur
semblent répondre à ses priorités donc
là il ya un enjeu immédiat
conjoncturelle donc ça c'est sur le plan
politique au sens strict mais plus
largement il y a évidemment un enjeu de
plus profond parce qu'on sait que le
pouvoir d'achat donc qu'ils aient
diminué à cause de l'inflation est bien
cette inflation elle creuse les
inégalités
c'est tout à fait mécanique même un
penseur le penseur de l'école à
néolibérale frédéric hayek disait avec
la reconnaissez dans les années 60 que
l'inflation ça détruisaient les classes
moyennes et puis que ça accentue de
façon très dangereuse le fossé entre
ceux qui détenaient un patrimoine et les
classes les couches supérieures et donc
c'est évident qu'il a il ya un souci
profond dans une société qui à ce point
crispée on ne peut pas se permettre de
ne rien faire donc il ya une urgence y
un contexte électoral il y a aussi un
enjeu vraiment la politique au sens
large auxquels il faut répondre c'est un
peu ce que j'ai un petit opportunistes
politiques et obligations que les autres
les deux mon capitaine il ya d'autres
pays européens qui dépensent quand même
moins d'argent public ont l'inflation
d'ailleurs est plus élevé thierry pech
est ce que emmanuel macron 7 converties
contraint et forcé une sorte de
dirigisme économique alors en effet
l'inflation est beaucoup plus élevé dans
beaucoup de pays européens à commencer
par notre grand voisin l'allemagne je
crois que l'état 8 ou 9 % parfois évalué
près de 10% donc on est à un niveau
assez bas d'inflation
parce qu'on a
mix énergétique particulier parce qu'on
a une agriculture qui néanmoins sert la
demande domestique en bonne part donc on
a une inflation plus modérée les autres
pays européens confrontés à cette
inflation font aussi un des choses assez
exceptionnel y a pas qu'en france qu'on
fait des ristournes d'échec bon et
d'ailleurs chacun rivalise d'imagination
pour trouver des réponses à la situation
qu'ils ne soient pas des réponses pyrène
parce que ça peut se retourner dans
trois mois dans six mois et si vous
dites face à un pic d'inflation
j'augmente le smic de jeu pas à 200
euros par exemple dans le cas de
jean-luc mélenchon et si à la fin de
l'année l'inflation retombe à 2 % la
réponse me caler pérenne alors que le
problème lui n'était pas donc beaucoup
de pays européens ont cette réflexion de
trouver des solutions les plus ciblés
possible les moins pérennes possible
pour répondre à une circonstance
déterminer la question c'est est-ce que
cette inflation va s'installer dans le
temps long auquel cas ces réponses là
seront mises en difficulté il ya un an
on va pas éternellement continuer de
doit il penser de l'argent public même
si on en parlait la thématique de
l'année était pas et pas forcément très
porteuse politiquement aujourd'hui mais
quand versement il ya un lien entre
l'inflation et la dette parce que à ce
qu'a dit madame je peux ajouter ce qui
est est ce que je partage qui était ce
qui aidera l inflation est un facteur de
creusement des inégalités c'est aussi
avec un phénomène qui ronge la rente et
la dette si on reste longtemps dans
cette situation vous avez des taux
d'intérêt très barré en valeur réelle en
réalité négatif avec une bce qui dit je
vais augmenter mais qui n'augmentent pas
tout de suite et qui continuent à
acheter sur le marché secondaire des
obligations d'état est bien en réalité
la dette font donc il ya un avantage qui
n'est pas commenter cette situation
c'est que la dette mécaniquement et
rongé par l'inflation bruno cautrès je
reviens sur ces annonces évidemment il
ya une part d'opportunisme politique
personne voilà personne n'est dupe mais
est ce que est ce que l'effet est
garanti oui ce que je veux dire parce
que l'annoncé faite aujourd'hui mais
les français vont pas toucher cet argent
ou en louent le concrétiser dans leurs
difficultés à boucler les fins de mois
tout de suite oui sauf pour certaines
mesures 'l'annonce tu pour la
prolongation de la ristourne sur
l'essence jusqu'à la fin du mois d'août
ça s'est tout de suite donc ça c'est oui
pour ceux qui étaient au moins nous
arrive c'est à dire c'est bon t'es
mais c'est vrai que sinon c'est beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus diffus c'est vrai que
là la difficulté pour ces pour ces
mesures c'est tour de montrer aux
français que ça fait vraiment bouger
leur mode de vie que ça a vraiment un
vrai impact par un mode de vie serait
que tout le monde le constate en faisant
ses courses tout a augmenté on a le
sentiment qu'il ya pas un seul produit
auquel on est habitué qui est au même
prix qu'il ya un mois ou deux mois donc
ça les gens le voient très concrètement
et la difficulté c'est effectivement
pour l'exécutif d'inscrire sa dans une
démarche de plus long terme l'un d'eux
pas seulement apparaître comme le
pompier qui vient colmater les chèques
les aides etc mais de donner du sens à
ça c'est vrai que sur le sens à donner à
ça c'est beaucoup plus compliqué tout de
suite est-ce que ça s'est inscrit dans
une démarche qui est au delà de
permettre aux français de faire face à
l'augmentation des prix est-ce que ça
s'inscrit dans une autre démarche qui
effectivement de revenir sur le thème
du salaire d'en revenir sur le thème
d'une certaine manière de la rétribution
du travail le chef de l'état le lisent
l'économie lorsqu'il en parle disent
toujours il faut pas perdre de vue qu'il
faut pas décourager le travail donc il
faut aider ceux qui prennent leur
voiture pour travailler dans qu'est ce
que ça s'inscrit dans une démarche un
peu plus générale parce que la
difficulté tout ça c'est le brouillard
que c'est en train de mettre
progressivement sur les dimensions de
plus longue durée le chef de l'état et
quelques jours publie une interview dans
la presse quotidienne oui nous parler de
grands projets la refondation le conseil
national de la fondation qu'il en est
sûr
matin ce qu'est ce qui se passe à la fin
de mon à la fin du mois sur mon compte
en banque il
faut
ça raconte que ça raconte une histoire
que ça tisse une narration à un moment
donné et c'est vrai que de ce point de
vue là c'est beaucoup plus difficile
parce que le chef de l'état doit pas non
plus se lier les mains trop longtemps
sur les objectifs pour lui dans un an
deux ans quand il espère qu'on sera
sorti de cette de cette inflation m'a
dit moi je pense que ça fera pas bouger
une voie dans la tête des électeurs
d'aujourd'hui parce que si on regarde
l'offre pour le politique de façon
comparative le programme devenu best of
beaucoup plus le point de vue du pouvoir
d'achat à tous les électeurs donc si les
électeurs votaient utilitaire pour
toucher de l'argent ils voteraient pour
le programme qui est le plus généreux à
leur égard après le pouvoir ne pouvait
pas non plus ne rien faire donc ils sont
obligés d'avancer les propositions faut
se souvenir que le pouvoir d'achat c'est
quelque chose dont ils trouveront
toujours eu du mal à se saisir acceptez
pas dans leurs préoccupations mais
soudée ou à l'automne dernier il était
obnubilé par les chiffres de l'insee et
qu'ils aient le pouvoir d'achat la
juvento autant augmenter pendant un
quinquennat
les chiffres sont avec nous qu'ils
ont ressenti des français à l'époque à
l'automne n'était pas celui là a été le
plein coûte de plus en plus cher et
affirme en homo mais mon plein de
courses au supermarché aussi donc c'est
une forme de déconnexion avec une forme
de retard à l'allumage et pendant la
campagne présidentielle on a vu que
celle qui avait estampillé cette
thématique c'était marine le pen
d'ailleurs davantage que jean luc
mélenchon l'époque qui lui de parler
d'environnement qui parlait de réformes
institutionnelles mais qui parlait pas
de pouvoir d'achat et là c'est un paquet
qui est fournie parce qu'il faut bien
dire quelque chose sur le pouvoir
d'achat avec des mesures qui sont je
vous rejoins conjoncturelle et non pas
structurelle sais pas combien de temps
cette crise va durer si elle va durer et
une réponse assez classique au fond qui
est on fait des chèques parce que c'est
la seule réponse qui a trouvé pour
l'instant le gouvernement juste un
comparatif avec l'allemagne doit pas
renier sur la thématique du du carburant
ils ont mis en place le le ticket de
transport public à 9 euros par mois pour
tous les transports publics histoire
d'avoir une mesure qui à la fois
permettre aux gens de se déplacer sans
payer trop cher et puis en plus avec un
bilan écologique qui leur paraît
favorable donc on voit bien qu'il ya
partout en europe c'est vrai des
formules qui sont à l'invention pour
pour essayer de répondre à cette
question de 2 d'inflation et qu'en
france on est quand même dans un truc
assez classique dont on fait des chèques
des subventions des aides ce n'est pas
déshonorant mais géré ce qui n'est pas
forcément présente évidemment ça agace
ou ça énerve l'opposition par exemple du
côté de l air les républicains on écoute
david lisnard le maire de cannes
président de l'association des maires de
france à quelques jours des législatives
il faut il faut bien avoir conscience de
la dimension politicienne de ce genre
d'annoncés c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
on fait un peu du clientélisme électoral
ça fait des mois que ça dure que le quoi
qu'il en coûte qui était nécessaire aux
premiers confinement et au début de la
crise est devenue une martingale pour
distribuer un argent que l'état n'a pas
évidemment il faut aider ceux qui sont
le plus en difficulté notamment les
personnes qui utilisent beaucoup leur
automobile des personnes dans la
ruralité et personnes un quartier
difficile évidemment et on doit et c'est
la dignité des civilisations qui aider
ces personnes là mais distribue de
l'argent public qui n'existe pas sans
beaucoup de contrôles en multipliant les
annonces avant les élections d'abord je
pense que c'est tromper les gens à terme
parce que l'inflation va encore plus
augmenté et c'est alimenter le mal que
l'on est censé combattre on distribue
l'argent un argent que l'état n'a pas
soufflé au clair quartier c'est un thème
qui pesait beaucoup dans la campagne
présidentielle et à cinq ans et qui
était au lycée sous les radars
aujourd'hui quoi très clair puis quand
on entend ça on se dit aussi s'il était
à la place du gouvernement aujourd'hui
que frétille parce que nous quand même
pour revenir sur le fond de la question
c'est quand même c'est thématique du
pouvoir d'achat du coût de la vie c'est
c'est vraiment le carburant des forces
populistes puisqu'on a évoqué mélenchon
donc il ya quand même une réponse à
apporter ça ne touche pas que les
classes modestes à coup ça touche aussi
les classes moyennes ces classes
moyennes qui ont bénéficié du
capitalisme et qui aujourd'hui ont le
sentiment que le capitalisme se retourne
contre elle justin pour bien comprendre
ce dont on parle il ya quand même des
chiffres qui montrent qu'il faut bien
agir sur ce problème en profondeur le
lorsque le différentiel entre les 10%
les plus pauvres en france et les 10%
les plus riches lorsqu'ils font leurs
courses d'après le cabinet de conseil
areces je crois je ne trompe pas les
plus pauvres perdent plus de 2% pouvoir
d'achat et les plus riches perles 0,7
pour cent donc moi je veux bien entendre
ce genre de choses mais j'ai a il faut
bien effectivement mettre de l'argent au
pot parce que sinon on ne peut pas s'en
sortir il ya quelque chose que je trouve
assez intéressant dans la réflexion et
dans le débat d'aujourd'hui autour de ça
c'est on est passé enfin pendant pas mal
d'années ont utilisé l'expression coût
de la vie et puis on est revenue à
l'expression pouvoir d'achat on ne parle
que de pouvoir d'achat c'est de la
sémantique qu'est ce que ça change
intéressant bah déjà dansé une
expression qui est liée à l'apparition
du salariat donc c'est une expression
ancienne en fait qui date de la fin du
19e et donc là on est plus sur le coût
de la vie on est sur le pouvoir d'achat
et il me semble que là aussi ça ça
rejoint quelque chose de profond dans la
société cédant pouvoir d'achat il ya
pouvoir et je pense que ça vient toucher
cette problématique plus en profondeur
un sentiment qui a gagné une partie de
la population française et pas
simplement les classes très modeste
c'est ce sentiment d'impuissance d'être
contraints d'être contraints dans son
existence et on est dans une société où
lorsqu'on ne peut pas manger comme on
veut north qu'on ne peut pas bouger
comme on veut lorsqu'on ne peut pas
consommer comme on veut alors que
d'autres le font plus aisés c'est
quelque chose qui est difficilement
supportable donc là encore il ya quelque
chose de profond auquel il faut répondre
et ses querelles et c'est bon là aussi
l'huile et dans l'électoralisme total je
trouve que ça mérite mieux en fait parce
que c'est vraiment des questions
profondes à résoudre je reviens sur ce
que vous dise tout à l'heure où nos
côtés sur la question de la cohérence on
peut aussi se poser cette question à
propos des mesures annoncées par la
nonne is la santé brigitte bourguignon
sur l'hôpital public doublement de la
rémunération des heures supplémentaires
possibilité d'exercer dès cet été pour
les élèves infirmiers les
aides-soignants donc pas totalement
formés ou pas complètement terminée
facilitation du cumul emploi-retraite à
quoi ça c'est à thierry pech avoir lancé
une mission flash si on annonça sans
avoir reçu les conclusions mais je
reviens sur la cohérence dont parlait
bono oui ça pose un petit problème de
cohérence à vous avez raison
en même temps je pense que tous les
décideurs publics pas dû seulement du
fait de la campagne je rejoins ce qui
vient d'être dit son saisie par
l'urgence et sont saisis aussi par le
sentiment que la société française est
assez éruptive on a pu le mesurer dans
les mois et les années passent et donc
des gestes doivent être faits
singulièrement à l'hôpital qui est
chauffé à blanc des personnels de santé
à l'hôpital sont mis à très rude épreuve
je pense en particulier aux infirmiers
aux infirmières qui sont souvent les
moins bien payés de l'hôpital ceux qui
ont des déplacements quotidiens les plus
longs parce que souvent ils habitent
loin et qui ont les horaires les plus
atypiques il faut s'imaginer un instant
ce qu'est la vie quotidienne de ses
personnels c'est très compliqué donc
élections pas élection il ya des
situations d'urgence qui appelle des
réponses d'urgence me semble-t-il oui un
problème d'incohérence peut-être dans la
gestion des décisions publiques mais moi
je reçois
positivement tout cas l'idée qu'il faut
urgemment répondre à l'urgence si vous
me permettez l'expression
bon mais on peut pas mélanger le
problème semble-t-il des personnels
hospitaliers avec les preuves que
peuvent vivre les petites classes
moyennes et les classes populaires en
général c'est quand même pas tout à fait
la même chose il ya une question
singulière de l'hôpital public qui doit
pas être mélangés avec les autres est
sûre
grande masse je crois qu'il ya une
question qu'on doit se poser c'est que à
force de faire des chèques des
ristournes etc on anesthésie aussi la
population qui de plus en plus le
sentiment que ya un problème il ya une
solution il ya un problème et un châle
en combien de temps ce sera le réflexe
de l'action publique à la fois je
comprend l'urgence et en même temps je
m'interroge sur les effets parce que
cette inflation elle vient d'où elle
vient pas d'une surchauffe de l'économie
nationale si l'inflation qui est importé
une inflation qui est le signe que nous
envoie la guerre aujourd'hui après le
signe que nous a envoyé la
désorganisation de la mondialisation à
la fin de la pandémie c'est signe là ne
sont pas bien perçu en réalité par la
population française sentiment que moi
on peut traverser ces épreuves ont fait
des chèques etc en réalité on est on est
en train d'entrer dans une quasi
économie de guerre et ça c'est pas
clairement porté politiquement ce n'est
pas dit et c'est la réalité
mes doudous l'appelle aussi lancé aux
entreprises c'est effectivement on peut
pas tout demander à l'état en permanence
il ya aussi là aussi ça ce réflexe là
lorsque nous dit finalement d'échec ceci
donc l'état vers lequel on s'en retourne
lorsqu'on est dans une situation de
désarroi comme celle d'aujourd'hui
le gouvernement bruno le maire lui-même
a lancé un appel il ya quelques jours
quelques semaines à l'endroit des
entreprises et ça me semble intéressant
aussi de lancer cette réflexion là et
quand même qui n'est quand même pas
normal puisqu'on est en train de parler
d'équité au sens large d'équité sociale
que ces entreprises qui ont bénéficié
lors du coc vide de quand même 2
milliards d' aide et de soutien ne met
pas elle aussi quand même la main enfin
nous ne se lance pas dans la bataille
mais aussi pour celles qui en ont les
moyens pour celles qui peuvent dégager
la même difficulté c'est la verticalité
si c'est une décision qui tombe d'en
obtenir
ban à qui il a discuté c'est de ne pas
rentrer dans cette fameuse spirale
inflationniste parce que voilà belmonte
le mystère c'est pourquoi c'est aux
pouvoirs politiques de venir chercher
les entreprises et pourquoi c'est pas
les salariés eux-mêmes qu'il tienne on a
vu une petite communauté citoyenne
pendant l'année c'est arrivé à un pardon
nous interrompre ya eu par exemple de la
part du secteur alors c'était contraint
et forcé par les difficultés de
recrutement le secteur café hôtellerie
restauration est sûre ils ont décidé
d'une augmentation
de 18% alors ça partait de très bas on
est d'accord mais également dans le
secteur de la volaille a eu quelques
mouvements oui mais nous on avait une
petite communauté citoyen les a
interrogés sur le pouvoir d'achat en
qualitatif il disait qu pas il disait
assez peu mon travail n'est pas assez
reconnu mon employeur me paye mal et je
vais aller chercher pour obtenir plus
que la question sociale classique est
d'ailleurs souvent beaucoup d'entre eux
aurait été légitime à faire cette
démarche mais il ne la faisais pas ils
disaient en revanche si je suis en
difficulté c'est parce que les
prélèvements obligatoires sont trop
élevés et d'une certaine façon non
seulement l'employeur n'est pas
l'interlocuteur auquel je dois me
confronter mais il est dans la même
situation
est donc la question sociale est devenue
une question de face à face avec l'état
et c'est ça aussi qui va pas parce qu'en
réalité il ya quand même des problèmes
de rémunération dans les secteurs que
vous avez cités c'est tout à fait clair
bien sûr et et dans d'autres on parlera
des professeurs dans le second débat on
sera en plein dans sept jeux sur
l'accusation d' électoraliste moi ça me
fait un peu sourire parce que d'un point
de vue de campagne électorale ce que
fait le gouvernement fasse que fait le
pouvoir est quand même assez déroutant
je reviens la question de l'urgence
intérêts mis trois semaines pour un
président sortant à avoir un premier
ministre un mois avoir un gouvernement
or les dossiers urgents il était sur la
table comme s'il avait fallu un mois
pour prendre la température goûter l'eau
du bain avant de s'y lancer enfin c'est
quand même aller tout pour sortir au
final des mesures dégainer comme ça
trois jours avant le avant le premier
tour ça interroge mais moi je suis pas
persuadé que d'un pur point de vue
électoraliste et calculs politiciens que
ce soit forcément efficace on voit
effectivement que la difficulté c'est
que ce que disait thierry pêcheurs
l'urgence est quand même là
effectivement la dimension éruptive la
société française est très forte nous on
a demandé récemment aux français quelle
était le mot qui incarnait le mieux la
manière dans la société française les
traites c'est le mot de mépris que les
français nous ont proposé comme le
premier mot quand même très graves comme
dysfonctionnements sociétale on va dire
de ce point de vue là et alors c'est
vrai qu'à bas que que le gouvernement en
place au moment des élections prennent
des mesures pour répondre aux attentes
on peut appeler ça l'électoralisme et
c'est aussi du bon sens de bons de bon
gouvernement et on a peu partagé on voit
qu'on tourne autour de la question du
rôle du rôle de l'état si on suit le
président de l'association des maires de
france récemment signataires d'une
tribune
c'est une solution libérale très dure
dix ans l'état c'est le régalien point
final on voit bien qu'en france si on
essaie d'appliquer cette cette solution
ça ça ne marche pas c'est simple pas ça
ne peut pas fonctionner l'éducation la
recherche la santé
tout un tas de missions de l'état en
france qui sont traditionnellement
installé depuis de nombreuses décennies
voire des siècles oui mais mais mais
pardon de nathan par là mais en
déshérence n'est pas loin à quoi on
améliore cette émission depuis des mois
on traite des thématiques liées selon
l'hôpital public la justice on va faire
des spéculations a dit m du permet de
l'action de 2,2 de l'état qui n'a pas
été posée non plus par la campagne
présidentielle donc il ya pas eu de
débat fondamental là dessus quand même
pendant la campagne présidentielle
lorsqu'on relit la tribune du chef de
l'état à la presse quotidienne régionale
on voit bien qu'elle ait deux dimensions
à la dimension de court terme et puis il
essaye de dire il ya aussi du long terme
envers enfers du structurel tout ça mais
le temps compte effectivement d'une
certaine manière effectivement il ya
déjà trop de temps qui est paquet paquet
passé en tout début de mandat le temps
compte on sera très rapidement à la mi
mandat au fonds sans s'en rendre compte
c'est après-demain et les ambitions de
deux il va je sens déjà là bref ça c'est
le temps du quinquennat c'est d'ailleurs
le défi puis en plus temps après on va
se concentrer un peu plus sur le les
législatives et les projections en
intentions de vote et ans et en sièges
que vous nous proposez avec avec ipsos
mais un dernier dernière question claire
chartier sûr sur cette thématique là le
défi qui est quand même très compliqué
c'est qu'on est à la fois dans des
mesures d'urgence et on le disait pour
les services publics dans des réformes
de fond qui sont ultra nécessaire et
donc ça pour le gouvernement l'état
qu'on conjuguer les deux en même temps
c'est quand même très complet surtout
faire comprendre parce que en effet il
ya deux temporalités
donc il ya en plus des questions que des
arguments des contre-arguments composent
l'opposition à l'exécutif tout ça ça va
coûter cher sa cause les déficits et la
dette et la réponse finalement du
gouvernement c'est de dire mon réformes
structurelles prenne plein emploi des
choses qui finalement prennent du temps
et qui ne se voit pas donc c'est vrai
que là c'est extrêmement difficile dans
le message de faire passer ça et en plus
il ya quelque chose de supplémentaire
c'est que en fait ça trouble un peu
aussi le logiciel mac ronis parce que
déjà on sait plus trop ce que c'est
puisque la faute de programmes là sur
quoi se retrouver on reste un petit peu
sur 2017 où on était sûr quand même la
question de la libération de des landes
et énergie du dynamisme et ses terres et
c'est pour ça que
dans une sorte de dirigisme économique
voilà je n'ai pas le contraire là c'est
compliqué parce qu'ils sont calmes en le
mot protection revient constamment dans
la bouche de bruno le maire et donald
macron donc déjà ça va pas du tout enfin
ça contredit complètement le logiciel et
puis il faut avouer il faut leur
reconnaître quand même qu'ils ont et
doivent ils subissent un peu le syndrome
du rocher de sisyphe parce que
finalement des éléments positifs à leur
actif comme la baisse du chômage qui
quand même tout à fait avéré vous le
disiez tout à l'heure thierry la france
grâce aux mesures qui ont été mises en
place fait mieux dans la hausse de
l'inflation que le reste de l'union
européenne ces 5 2% chez nous 7 % pour
la moyenne des pays européens donc ça ce
sont des arguments qui devrait
finalement intervenir dans le débat et
de certaine manière c'est étrange et
surtout pour le chômage donc en plus
pour le chômage dont on a tant parlé en
france sans fab souvenez-vous de cette
inversion de la courbe du chômage et des
dames en fait on a l'impression qu'on
est dans une société tellement polarisé
idéologiquement que ces éléments de la
réalité en fait ne ne sont pas
considérés à dire que vraiment on
n'arrive pas à appréhender la réalité
donc c'est une difficulté supplémentaire
et du côté du gouvernement c'est une
énorme difficulté quand même parce que
finalement ils ne peuvent même pas se
reposer sur des éléments concrets
objectif qui montre que quand même
quelque chose fonctionne dans ce qu'ils
nous proposent mais est ce qu'elle vous
passionne cette campagne législative
ah oui j'adore voilà j'aime bien
semblant banon mais non voyons ici il
suffit d'avoir enfin cette réponse moi
j'ai éclaté de rire elle passionne
personne et d'ailleurs je viens à la pas
lieu bon alors ça tombe bien on va quand
même en débattre et je propose à
jonathan du prise de nous rejoindre
puisque on va s'appuyer bruno sur
l'étude que vous avez menées avec ipsos
bonsoir sopra steria pour le monde
désintérêt des français pour ce scrutin
mais vous le disiez ce qu'elle vous
passionne cette campagne va en tout cas
les français on a l'impression que ça
les passionne pas tant que ça et il ya
plusieurs explications à cela comme
l'étude du cevipof et ipsos l'avancent
l'absence de débat par exemple entre les
grandes formations politiques le fait
aussi que les candidats à la députation
et 20 pour beaucoup ce sont des inconnus
en politique il ya aussi la discrétion
du rn qui mène cette campagne un peu à
bas bruit ou encore l'omniprésence de la
nuque c'est vrai qui a capté beaucoup de
la lumière alors pour ce qui est des des
chiffres l'ipso se révèle que 70% des
personnes se disent quand même intéressé
par les législatives mais alors ce
chiffre s'il peut paraître un peu
satisfaisant on va dire et quand même en
trompe l'oeil puisque en fait il est en
recul de quatre points par rapport au
même baromètre d'il ya deux semaines est
à noter aussi tout de même tomac si on
les additionne 30 % des français
déclarent être moyennement intéressés
voire pas intéresser du tout par un
scrutin est alors de 7
athony quasi général résulte évidemment
un risque d'abstention record c'est ça
c'est le risque et le baromètre prédit
d'ailleurs 46 % de participation à plus
ou moins deux points près pour rappel en
2017 la participation au premier tour
des législatives
elle fut de 48,7 % et à l'époque on
s'était dit qu'elle n'avait jamais été
aussi basse et c'était le cas on peut
quand même aussi tempérer un peu ce
risque de l'abstention 1 par rapport aux
cas qui s'est produit à la
présidentielle finalement les personnes
se sont décidés à aller voter impôts
dernier moment quoi ça c'est ça s'est
joué dans la dernière heure au niveau
des équilibres politiques
il n'y a pas énormément de surprises et
ce nom là rien de neuf sous le soleil on
va dire ce qu'on savait déjà se
consolide la majorité présidentielle
nuls sont au coude à coude
respectivement données vous le voyez à
28 et 27 5% des voix au premier tour
suit le rn à 20% puis la droite qui est
très à la peine 11% alors qu'est ce que
ça donne en terme de sièges dans les
projections ensemble pourrait rafler
entre 275 et 315 sièges la nuque 160 à
200 en revanche il faut expliquer une
petite subtilité en ce qui concerne le
rn parce que le parti en fait si peu
obtenir 20 % des voix au niveau national
et ben en fait il pourrait récolter que
20 à 55 sièges à l'issue du second tour
à la faute au mode de scrutin ça c'est
pas nouveau ça fait des années que le
rassemblement national où auparavant le
front national proteste oui ça fait des
années qu'ils s'en plaignent parce que
les législatives c'est un scrutin
majoritaire à deux tours qui lui est
mécaniquement défavorable ainsi le rn
parvient à se hisser au second tour de
certaines circonscriptions ce qui est
déjà pas simple au vu des deux blocs qui
qui va falloir battre il doit ensuite
remporté ses duels et là encore ça se
complique parce que les reports de voix
des autres partis face à eux réduisent
mécaniquement leurs chances de s'imposer
et donc réduisent leurs chances
d'obtenir des sièges et c'est pour ça
que marine le pen est bien tout
simplement le réclame une
proportionnelle intégrale depuis des
années elle a encore redit ce matin sur
europe 1
malgré la promesse faite par les manuels
mâcon il ya cinq ans de mettre en oeuvre
la proportionnelle malgré la pression
mise par monsieur bayrou pour obtenir de
ce mode de scrutin qui est celui de tous
les pays de l'union européenne à tous
sans exception et bien emmanuel macron a
trahi sa promesse et il n'a pas mis en
oeuvre la proportionnelle la
proportionnelle ça permettrait à
l'ensemble des courants politiques
d'être représenté à hauteur de ce qu'il
représente en nombre de voix voilà
thomas et on s'en souvient en 2017
savait déjà coûté cher aux arènes le
parti n'avait obtenu que six députés
alors que marine le pen elle avait fait
34 % second tour la présidentielle merci
l'attend bruno cautrès effectivement
cette proportionnelle ce sera peut
l'imaginer pour la prochaine mandature
c'est le cadeau que kavanagh qu'on va
laisser à son successeur tout cas on
peut pas laisser les choses en l'état on
tourne on tourne autour de cette
question depuis très longtemps en france
on a élu en 2010 est un véritable
paradoxe une assemblée nationale
profondément renouvelé beaucoup de
nouveaux députés issus en particulier de
nouvelles couches de la société
pas forcément des couches défavorisées
d'ailleurs un gros renouvellement aussi
générationnel beaucoup plus de parité
l'âge moyen des députés qui a chuté donc
quelque chose de plutôt positif en
système démocratique et en même temps
cette assemblée de 2017 elle a obtenu
les coefficients statistiques de
disproportionnalité ce que les
chercheurs calculent comment passez des
voix au siège les petites distordue de
toute l'histoire de la vème république
et notamment du fait que le
rassemblement national n'a pas du tout
retrouver en nombre de sièges les voix
qui s'étaient portées sur sur lui
françaises soumises aussi mettons
beaucoup plus rassemblement national
donc on voit qu'il ya un souci un souci
institutionnels le mode de scrutin mais
aussi l'ensemble du système
institutionnel parce que le mode de
scrutin est typiquement le genre de
réformes qu'on ne peut pas faire avec un
seul paramétrage se sont tous show mode
de scrutin on est obligé reparler du
reste et parler du reste ça veut dire
faut effectivement le coeur du sujet le
système présidentiel
le rôle du parlement donc voilà on voit
qu'à un sujet en france qui est
d'essayer de revitaliser de redonner vie
de redonner un souffle à la vie à la vie
démocratique parce que dans les
électorats concernés le sentiment de
colère et de frustration est immense ce
qui caractérise électorale du front
national du rassemblement national
parlons en premier c'est cette colère
non seulement la colère sociale et la
colère politique les deux les deux au
fond
brasier de la crise et j'ai des jeunes
oui alors je suis d'accord avec vous sur
l'importance de re tisser une certaine
façon un lien entre les français et
leurs élus mais je repose la question
sur parce que vous l'avez évoqué c'est
quand même un cadeau je mets plein de
limay empoisonné que emmanuel macron
laissera son successeur parce que ça va
effrité ou affaiblir le pouvoir
présidentiel est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec cette idée thierry pech
non je suis pas complètement d'accord
d'abord il veut pas andy quelque chose
qui est faux il faut le rappeler les
manuels macro n'a jamais promis une
proportionnelle intégrale et s'était
engagé une 12e pour céret et s'était
associée au paquet de réformes de
révision constitutionnelle il a été
sabordée par gérard larcher dans ces
mêmes murs bon voilà c'est ça la vraie
histoire du sujet
deuxièmement on est des cons on a une
constitution qui a été pensée fait est
conçu pour assurer à l'exécutif une
majorité parlementaire homogène stable
et forte et c'est ce que nos
institutions produisent jusqu'ici voir
jusqu'ici y compris avec les effets de
distorsion très peu démocratique de 2017
mais aussi le 2012 etc ben voilà les
institutions font ce pourquoi elles ont
été faites elle donne un gouvernement
une stabilité et c'est quand même
l'obsession c'est l obsession du général
de gaulle produire de la stabilité
exécutive troisièmement et là je suis
pas complètement d'accord la
proportionnelle n'oblige pas à réviser
le reste est d'ailleurs la preuve en est
c'est que sous les mêmes institutions en
86 on a fait de la proportionnelle
intégrale
des institutions ne sont pas tombées par
terre
ce que ça change c'est que plus vous
faites de proportionnelle plus vous
augmentez les chances d'avoir des
gouvernements de coalition
la marine le pen dit quelque chose de
juste on est le dernier pays de l'union
européenne à pratiquer le scrutin
majoritaire uninominal à deux tours aux
élections législatives tous les autres
font de la proportionnelle et tous les
autres connaissent des expériences de
coalition nombreuses les allemands les
premiers mais aussi les italiens etc et
pourquoi pas nous
qu'est-ce que alors en effet oui mais ça
c'est compatible avec avec le finalement
le pouvoir présidentiel est tel qu'on
s'y est habitué de la rivière 5e
république n'ont pas la vème république
2.0 la celle qu'on vit depuis 2002 et le
quinquennat mais la vème république
d'avant l intégrer l'idée de
cohabitation et dans la cohabitation le
pouvoir présidentiel était plus faible
mais est-ce qui est ce que pour autant
l'exécutif était moins légitime nous
entre 97 et 2002 le pays a été gouvernée
des réformes importantes ont été faites
jacques chirac était président la
république il était certes moins
puissant que lorsqu'il avait une
majorité qui lui ressemblait à
l'assemblée mais le pays a été gouvernée
et d'exécutif existait donc la
constitution de la vème permet
permettait et peut-être permettra dans
le futur si on revient à plus de
proportionnelle avoir deux régiments
fait un régime très présidentialiser
quand les majorités sont congruente et
un régime beaucoup moins
présidentialiser lorsqu'elles ne sont
pas et ce détail près que cohabitation
n'est pas coalition la culture du fait
majoritaire est inversée parce que
l'opposition est majoritaire c'est juste
vous avez raison et d'ailleurs ça me
permet de préciser une chose c'est que
le vrai risque d'une future cohabitation
sait que ça ne sera pas le cas là si
jamais la nuque gagne mais il faut
envisager une situation où personne
accepte d'aller à matignon est où là
c'est la crise de régime parce que la
conséquence d'un refus de ce qui fait la
mise en cause du président de la
république lui-même mais alors ça
rejoint et on va écouter ce que disait
manuel mon pari le choix c'était il ya
deux jours parce que je rembobine et le
prénom république donne une interview à
la presse quotidienne régionale dans
lequel il rappelle qu'aucun parti
politique ne peut imposer un nom au
président et ça provoque cette réaction
de manuel mon part c'était sur sud radio
campagne on essaye de convaincre les
électrices et les électeurs vont le
faire arguments contre arguments et
c'est vrai que dans les arguments qui
ont été défendues par le président de la
république franchement ça ne tient pas
la route quand il nous dit toute façon
jean luc notion peut pas être premier
ministre parce que je ne nommerai pas
bassi bonhomme tu vas le nommer ils sont
pour cette soupe bonhomme claire
chartier parce que il ya une il ya une
accusation en arrogance parfois
justifiées qui vise emmanuel macron qui
est souvent emporté par d'ailleurs les
les insoumis une forme d'arrogance dans
cette formulation aussi oui puis elle a
effectivement ça peu comment dire ça
peut les desservir dans le sens où l'un
des arguments qui agitaient contre la
nuque c'est précisément cela c'est à
dire des députés enfin les et député
insoumis l'exemple qu'ils ont donnée
dans la législature précédente c'était
quand même un peu de mettre le bazar de
faire de l'obstruction systématique dont
il ya un mode d'exercice en fait 2 lors
de leur mandat qui n'est pas forcément
très rassurant vu la situation donc ce
genre de deux d'expression peut renvoyer
à ça aussi c'est qu'on va aller où on va
faire faillite et c'est vrai que les
électeurs n'ont pas forcément envie de
ça en ce moment vu toute la somme de
problèmes qui s'amoncellent sur sur les
têtes avec le traîne avec tout le reste
donc si on ajoute à cela le la police
eut c'est vrai que je pense que ça ça
peut les desservir auprès de prese
lecteurs moi je voulais juste ajouter
quelque chose qui ces personnels mais
dans le par rapport aux législatives il
ya quelque chose qui me semble un peu
être dissonant par rapport à l'esprit du
temps aussi c'est qu'on voit des gens
débarquer dans des circonscriptions en
fait et qui sont parachutés cette
pratique du parachutage me semble aller
tout à fait à l'encontre de nouveau
c'est pas de vous non c'est pas nouveau
mais ça me semble aller à l'encontre de
l'esprit du temps où on a précisément en
vie les gens les citoyens ou envie de
connaître ceux à qui s'adresse de savoir
ce qu'ils font et ne pas être pris pour
des imbéciles donc là un parachutage on
vois quelqu'un quelque part on sait très
bien parce que c'est un calcul du parti
en question ça ne répond pas finalement
aux exigences des citoyens localement
donc on voit qu'il ya un calcul
politique des petits vraiment absolument
déconnectés du terrain et ça je pense
que c'est aussi un élément qui commence
à devenir assez choquant et qui peut
susciter une sorte de désaffection pour
ce type de scrutin je voudrais revenir
sur les quais bas ça se rejoint sur la
question de la participation de bruno
cautrès on a entendu les lessives que
qui sont prévus dans votre dernier
études pour pour le monde est-ce que
effectivement j'en ai attendu prise
l'évoquait et il peut y avoir un rebond
dans les derniers jours un peu comme ce
qu'on a vécu l'avant avant le premier
tour de ce qu'on voit que des effets de
polarisation qui sont en train de se
faire à travers la campagne on voit
qu'effectivement c'est de plus en plus
maintenant le combat au sommet entre la
coalition ensemble et la coalition de la
nuque effectivement et ça on mesure mal
encore mais ça peut effectivement avoir
des effets de mobilisation et notamment
la question pourra se posent encore plus
sur le deuxième tour que va faire le que
vont faire les résultats du premier tour
au principe aux électorats aux deux
principaux électorat c'est vrai qu'à
gauche si on voit à la fois qu'il ya
beaucoup de candidats de gauche
qualifier au deuxième tour ce qui va
sans aucun doute se passer des ministres
pour qu'ils pourraient être en
difficulté dans certaines
circonscriptions est ce que tout ça va
pas avoir un effet de motivation et du
côté de l'exécutif au contraire un
réflexe d'aller se mobiliser pour donner
une majorité emmanuel macron dont voilà
envoie on voit qu'une intrigue autour
effectivement de ses effets de
mobilisation une polarisation deux
dernières de dernière minute qui est son
je crois c'est assez intéressant assez
assez important le le
dans nos dans nos données on a toujours
un scénario quand même d'une coalition
ensemble qui est majoritaire alors la
vraie question c'est majorité absolue
une majorité relative au ras de la
fourchette pour parler puis derrière il
ya la deuxième question qui est qu'elle
est là quelle est la distance qui sépare
s'il y avait une majorité relative
quelle est la distance qui sépare la
coalition ensemble de la majorité
absolue est ce que ces quelques sièges
ou est-ce que ces dix quinze vingt
sièges 6 et plus 10 15 20 sièges ça pose
une toute autre question que si c'est
simplement 3 ou 4 3 ou 4 sièges sur la
sur la question des parachutages et
c'est pour vous dire c'est effectivement
quand on regarde d'entre d'eux de
manière très détaillée les près de sept
mille candidats on trouve des cas un peu
exotique de candidats qui revendiquent
même leur parachute agent je sais que je
ne suis pas du coin mais justement c'est
bon c'est bon c'est mon natoo j'en ai
trouvé quelques uns dans la base des
7000 ans est-il candidat et vous avez
même un candidat dans l'est de la france
qui appelle à ne pas voter pour lui
j'ai en parlé des candidats admis à
l'ischio ont choisi de d'afficher un
caneton
à la place du visage et des candidats
inversement des animaux de compagnie
d'âge était un problème mais est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui ce qu'on appelait
autrefois l'ancrage politique est
réellement un avantage
de moins en moins des amis du cevipof me
disait d'élections d'élection c'est un
avantage mais si ça compte et en réalité
la post position des législatives après
les présidentielles faisait que la
présidentielle emporté la législative
quelle que soit l'ancienneté des
candidats dans les îles on y revient
on vote plus pour mma kron pour jean luc
mélenchon pour le candidat
qui est encore sur la fia pression c'est
un parti continuent à insister
sur les progrès sur les pendant leur
campagne électorale sur la propagande
électorale il ya plus le cv des gens
mais juste le nom et puis jean luc
mélenchon ou le nombre et marine le pen
c'est la même chose juste une chose on
peut avoir un premier tour avec un très
bon score de la nuque et un semblant de
victoires pour un nul et al'inverse un
second tour avec une plus large victoire
pour m nl macron que prévu si un effet
entre les deux tours de repoussoir à
l'égard de l'électorat de jean luc
mélenchon enfin du programme de
récupération qui dispose pour quand même
très peu de réserves de one cet éventuel
merci merci à tous d'avoir participé à
ce premier débat